hi so today we're going to be talking
about illustration typically when you'll
need to filter in the lab you'll need
drench filter you'll need a syringe and
you'll also need a vial so normally how
you feel to her sample is you have your
sample you get some of your sample with
your syringe you attach your syringe
filter onto the luer lock syringe and
then you grab your vial and you filter
into the vial and there you go your
sample is ready to go into the HPLC but
if you have a lot of samples and you
don't want to have as many plastic
supplies in the lab or glass supplies
there is a new product that replaces all
of this with just this this is a filter
model now to help us demonstrate how a
filter bottle works we're gonna bring
our friend here the French press so the
way the French press works is you start
with a dirty sample in this case coffee
grounds add water you add the sample to
the container and you put the press
filter over the top to push down the
junk gets trapped at the bottom and the
filtrate comes nice and clean to the top
[Music]
your filter vial
what you can do is you can just simply
take up some of your sample and put it
into
the filter bottle collection area you
see there's a fill line right there you
just want to make sure you don't go past
that fill line and then you take your
filter and you simply press it down and
that's ready to go into the HPLC
[Music]
[Music]